Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Creating geometry for a computer game or a
movie is a very long and arduous task.
For instance, if we would like to populate
a virtual city with buildings, it would cost
a ton of time and money and of course, we
would need quite a few artists.
This piece of work solves this problem in
a very elegant and convenient way: it learns
the preference of the user, then creates and
recommends a set of solutions that are expected
to be desirable.
In this example, we are looking for tables
with either one leg or crossing legs.
It should also be properly balanced, therefore
if we see any of these criteria, we'll assign
a high score to these models.
These are the preferences that the algorithm
should try to learn.
The orange bars show the predicted score for
new models created by the algorithm - a larger
value means that the system expects the user
to score these high, and the blue bars mean
the uncertainty.
Generally, we're looking for solutions with
large orange and small blue bars, this means
that the algorithm is confident that a given
model is in line with our preferences.
And we see exactly what were looking for - novel,
balanced table designs with one leg or crossed
legs.
Interestingly, since we have these uncertainty
values, one can also visualize counterexamples
where the algorithm is not so sure, but would
guess that we wouldn't like the model.
It's super cool that it is aware how horrendous
these designs looks.
It may have a better eye than many of the
contemporary art curators out there.
There are also examples where the algorithm
is very confident that we're going to hate
a given example because of its legs or unbalancedness,
and would never recommend such a model.
So indirectly, it also learns how a balanced
piece of furniture should look like, without
ever learning the concept of gravity or doing
any kind of architectural computation.
The algorithm also works on buildings, and
after learning our preferences, it can populate
entire cities with geometry that is in line
with our artistic vision.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!